da macht es einfach komplett ab jetzt
auch egal ich meine hatte ich noch nie
dann sehe ich mal wie es aussieht
[Musik]
die haare dürfen hier nicht durchfallen
lassen
so leute was geht ab herzlich willkommen
zum neuen video wir machen heute was
sehr interessant ist und zwar und zwar
bin ich ja auch in quarantäne sozusagen
also ich bleib teilt fassen und zu hause
friseure haben zu das heißt wir haben
jetzt hier plan b und das ist marie bei
meine haare sind echt sehr sehr lang
geworden ich war beim friseur vor
eineinhalb monaten also wir haben ja
dieses foto das gesehene das bin ich
euch hier mal ein
so hatte ich schon meine haare also
ziemlich kurz deswegen ich würde sagen
das lohnt sich das jetzt wieder zu
machen
dieter helms ist es besser zu machen als
achso ja das ist glaube ich nicht schwer
sein einziger das nicht so schlimm ich
habe immer meine haare so geschnitten
ja eben deswegen ein thema aber nur
design
nein nein oder ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß und ich wünsche euch viel spaß
aber wenn du es wagst wenn wir nicht
echt böse ja doch was soll ich machen
ich kann es ja nicht blöd und ja sie
sich doch eh keiner in der nächsten zeit
mache am besten alles auf eine auf eine
linie eine höhere elke lange willst es
erstmal das längst innere dass ich da
ist das längste das oder wie viel das
weiß ich mir nicht ja sagen einfach mal
an am besten aber ein bisschen länger
lassen als an den sollten ja hast du
auch eine schere ja auch leute erst
deine haare jetzt hier ab die längeren
habe
jetzt erst mal hierhin ich wünschte ich
hätte eine spange geht da kannst du mir
mal eine spanne von mir das kann
manchmal braucht man damit man nämlich
den übergang sehen kann
also da wo der übergang stattfinden soll
maxis lieber wenn die direkt hier alle
auf einer länge sind oder willst du dass
sie hier noch ein bisschen länger am
besten macht es nicht mit übergangen
weil das klingt so ähnlich sind
sollte das wissen ja also dass das muss
man dafür haben jahrelange ausbildung
und gehen wir am besten so hinter mich
gebracht müssen wir noch nachholen ich
will dass er abtreten gute friseure
können auch ohne aufgefunden
da ich mal hier ansetzen ist dann aber
weder schneidet jetzt von mir ich hab
nur schon mal angesetzt das ist richtig
ja jetzt auch schon jetzt hast du schon
vor packt jetzt kannst du jedoch nicht
wieder länger machen ja man kann die eh
nicht länger machen das ist schon die
längst ist das hier überhaupt die haare
oder ist das hier nur für ist das wird
für die haare oder ist das hier ja das
kann ich nicht gebrauchen sogar ein
peter ist das zu kurz
aber es geht nicht kürzt das eigentlich
länger drei millimeter nochmal über 8 es
geht aber nicht länger doch hier aber
jetzt braucht mit alter du brauchst
natürlich das ist doch gefährlich damit
kannst du mich doch schneiden du
brauchst 1 auf support unterbrechung
so jetzt hast du auch ein aufsatz mal
bekommen
danach so wie es eingebracht hat dann
macht man so wie es eingeplant war 6 mm
oder lieber 88 ja ich verstehe nicht wie
man das auf zeit wie soll das glaube ich
nicht friseurin werden besser
jetzt machen du scheinst gleich meinen
ohren wenn du so weitermachst eine idee
oder nee das war mal ries idee also ich
meine haare wollte schneiden lassen und
sieht das jetzt schon besser aus dass
deine haare gleiche ausschneiden
die spitzen die muss auch mal wieder
[Musik]
leute ich glaube keiner von euch will
meine von mir die haare gekommen
seine mutter hat mich glaube ich dann
ähnlich sieht jetzt machen auch ein
bisschen du hast ja nicht mal dann die
haare auch mal bitte neben walter neben
mir abhängen und nicht eines eindruck da
liegen lassen
ich bin ja voll mit haaren so daneben
und weg nicht wieder oben drauf tun habe
ich schon im mund
also ich muss gleich auf jeden fall
duschen gehen sonst kratzt es komplett
oder warum weiß ich jetzt noch mal unten
auf 3 geht man hier die haare wirklich
alex trägt ja gleich nach oben
zugeschnitten
sebastian das selber schneiden sie gar
nicht mal so schlecht aus
hast du auch an seiten schon viel weg es
fühlt sich immer noch so lange mir sonst
mache einfach mal weg über ein tier vor
die langen haare die ich nicht
wegkriegen
[Musik]
hallo und mach das mal hier bei der
jammer kopf runter guck mal wie eine
spinne auf einer hose immer dann wenn du
willst dass ich packe danach weiter wir
ehrlich jetzt hier ist gegen einen
lichtmast hast du die gesehen guck mal
hier
du musst mal richtig da jetzt ran sonst
wird das nix ja aber du wirst ja sehen
das gerade auch ganz gut wenn die ganze
welt sagen dass ich das gut
nachvollziehbar wie die aussieht
ok und jetzt mit der schere nur nach
oben jetzt aber du musst auch mit dem
kam das so halt plan was das schnellste
über paare ab hat aber ich muss jetzt
erstmal hier oben aber das abschneiden
dann mache ich weiß nicht ob man hinten
war unbedingt was abschneiden sollte vor
allem ich an diesem wirbel
sonst stehen die da hinten machen wir
lieber vorne der friseur stellt auch bei
mir immer hier von hier nach hinten und
nicht von hinten nach vorne bestimmt es
hat auch glaube ich schon ein grund
warum man als friseurin die ausbildung
nicht innerhalb von zwei wochen machen
dann nimmst du recht aber dann musste
sie dann ruhe und dann hältst du dich
hier drunter fest und kann es dann hier
abschneiden was ist daran so schwer
ja aber du hast doch einfach nein du
musst mit deiner hand natürlich darunter
halten
[Musik]
und du bewegst dich auch die ganze zeit
so kann hat er nichts werden jetzt ist
es richtig unordentlich alles wie sieht
es aus um geld und nichts möchte die
alle absagen gerade ich habe eigentlich
gedacht dass du es ist ein bisschen wie
nichts hinkriegen kannst ja weißt du was
weil bald wieder deine haare nicht nach
sind peter um mir mal bitte eine flasche
wasser jetzt noch da hast du vielleicht
mal waren wir durchschneiden geht das
nicht deswegen nicht merkt dass gerade
dieses jahr gar nicht mehr struktur weiß
was ich mache das jetzt so dass ich das
hier
ich stelle jetzt den rasierer auf 3 13
millimetern einmal sterne haare oben
einfach 13 millimeter wie viel sind 13
millimeter so macht es einfach komplett
ab jetzt ist auch egal ich meine hatte
ich noch nie dann so wie es aussieht
indoor freundin und ich habe ja auch
noch mit den augen zu und durch dann war
die letzte färbung blondierung oben halt
um so ein okay leute da hatte ich muss
anderswo nicht gegen den harmlosen
solange du nicht lachst ist ja alles in
ordnung
ok jetzt nicht dass mein gott deine
haare alte muslimin vorne das nochmal
ordentlich
[Musik]
wie lange dauert es noch man muss das
schon alles auf eine länge bringen oder
willst du doch ab und zu ein paar
kleinere olympia ja klar ich ja noch
jung es laut länger als man denkt alle
komponenten laufen kommt wenn nicht in
der quarantäne wann soll man sonst
ausprobieren hast du jetzt kommen hier
ist auch kalt ein bisschen ja irgendwie
doch länger habe bekommen wir hier jetzt
zu spüren das kannst du nichts sagen
wollte selber fabriziert das sind doch
bestimmt irgendwo noch haare dran oder
die noch guck mal hier hin ist das doch
noch länger als hier ist automatisch so
weit zu sagen im wirbel hast genau
richtig damals ich habe alexander ganz
abrasierten das sieht jetzt so scheiße
aus mussten safeware ich mache hier
erstmal außen sehen wir uns dann später
wieder vielleicht ändern nur ich hab
noch nie habe schlicht keine ahnung was
verpackt dann fahre ich nach hause
sollte was geht ab willkommen alter ja
und ich hatte noch nie in meinem ganzen
leben außer als kleinkind meine haare so
kurz ich weiß nicht ein gangster und 2
also schreibt er sehr gerne eure meinung
in die kommentare
es gibt einige stellen die müssen
absolut noch nachgebessert werden das
weiß wie ich trotzdem ist das jetzt halt
bei rausgekommen
also die sind überall ist einen
zentimeter lang außenseiten und hier
unten sind die drei millimeter das sieht
man auch voll verkackt ich weiß es auch
nicht ich kann jetzt nicht ich lasse sie
einfach so wachsen jetzt wieder ich
hoffe ihr findet das video ganz amüsant
ich habe es schon fast fertig
geschnitten ist eigentlich ganz lustig
augenringe sieht man dezent schreibt
sehr gerne eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare ich bin mal gespannt was ich
da so lesen werde und auf instagram
nicht zum foto mit den haaren
jack sock 30 alex wie abonniert den
kanal abonniert auch sehr gerne meinen
zweikanal alex v da kommt jeden tag
reaktion und das war's dann wirst du
schauen dass du nach irgendwelchen folgt
haut rein ich habe übrigens schon jetzt
wachsen getan aber braucht man
eigentlich gar nicht das ist absolut
kein unterschied
[Musik]